[موسيقى]
لم يقتبس
أهلا وسهلا بك إلى la chaux-de-fonds
مرحبا
[موسيقى]
اسمي اوريلي بروكلين وأنا
يعمل في المتحف الدولي
من صناعة الساعات في لا شو دو فون لذلك
مرمم نعمل نعمل
على ال
يعترض صانعو الساعات كل يوم على أن هذا
إما الساعات الساعات كل
ساعة رملية هذا الرجل هناك ونذهب
تحضير الأشياء التي تحطمت
تالفة أو لم تعد تعمل
وظيفة وبعد ذلك نقوم بتنظيفها و
ثم الصعود لعملها
قبل كل شيء ، عليك أن تحب الميكانيكا و
ثم رقة دقة
الحياة الجيرية في صناعة الساعات حيث
هناك العديد من المصانع التي
يتم إنشاء هنا يدعمون
منطقة بأكملها
[موسيقى]
جيد وباتريك couillaud أنا
المدير العام للقيام بعمل جيد
جاء جيرار بيريو ليستقر فيها
لا شو دو فون في عام 1856 أود أن أقول ذلك
لا شو دو فون هي واحدة من المدن التي يوجد فيها
تتعثر على خريطة جنيه
الشركة المصنعة الرئيسية للساعة
أود أن أقول أن la chaux-de-fonds هو ملف
مدينة مهمة جدا
حان الوقت متنوعة للغاية
يمكن أن يكون إنتاج العالم
بضعة أشهر إلى عدة سنوات
عندما تكون حركة معقدة للغاية
سعر العوالم متنوع قليلا في القضية
بواسطة gérard perrigault سيبدأ عند
حوالي 7000 دولار ويذهب
تصل إلى أكثر من مليون دولار هذه
عناصر مختلفة من العالم كله
يجعل أحد الوالدين فرديًا إلى
مرات التصميم ومن يصنع ذلك
يجعل هذا المكان فريدًا وخبرة
الذين لديهم هوس بالوقت
التمكن من حساب الوقت
مرحباً بالجميع - جوليا والون أنا أنت
مرحبا بكم في متجري أذهب إليه
صناعة الساعات في لا شو دو فون جدا
في مجال صناعة الساعات منذ ذلك الحين
أكثر من 20 عاما وأنا كذلك
جامع الساعات لأكثر من
20 سنة أيضا
كما نحن في حياة
بتعبير أدق ، لدينا
في بعض الأحيان فرصة للحصول على عملات معدنية
وهي فريدة من نوعها
لدينا دائما المزيد من الأشياء
الرجل الوقت الثمين لإصلاح هنا
لدي مثال لطيف من عالم الجيب
إنسان آلي سأعمل هذا
ساعة
يتطلب معرفة هائلة بعد ذلك
يسلط الضوء أيضًا على كل المعرفة
من منطقتنا من مهدنا
أنا محظوظ لأنني كنت كذلك دائمًا
في مكان ما مشروط قليلا برعاية
بجو صناعة الساعات لأنني كبيرة
كان الأب دائمًا منغمسًا في صناعة الساعات
هي والد جدي أيضا
لأهميتها الحيوية بالنسبة لـ
الجير دي فون
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]